For centuries
demons have roamed our world trapping
humans
in a vicious cycle possessing and
feeding off their victims energy
until the body burns itself out
this cycle must be broken but who has
the power to break it
the hellstroms
there he is my boy
mommy dearest i know you set something
loose on this world
what was it i think you know
no stone unturned
this family's unnatural behavior
i've never experienced anything like it
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new marvel ghost rider
trailer for the hellstrom tv series
we'll break it down there's obviously a
whole bunch of easter eggs here i'll
explain what's going on if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos
obviously there's going to be a bunch of
Wandavision episodes coming later this
year in the mandalorian season 2
episodes i'll be doing videos for all
that stuff
i'll also start doing a disney plus
giveaway in those videos once those
episodes actually do start
but starting with the big stuff first
obviously number five the new marvel
hellstrom series just released a ghost
rider trailer with a couple cool easter
eggs connecting to bigger supernatural
marvel crossover stuff
the chapter 1 title card in that is all
about the demonic cycle
it talks all about demons walking on
earth for centuries trapping victims
feeding off their energy through
possession until the body
burns itself out with graphics of a
flaming skull in the trademark ghost
rider chain with some cool sound effects
the demonic cycle that it speaks of is
obviously a reference to a couple ghost
rider things
one to the cycle of the ghost rider
mantle being passed down with the spirit
of vengeance possessing different hosts
through human history jenny ketch robbie
reyes the other versions
is also a clever reference to
ghostwriter's motorcycle as in his
cycle that he rides the cycle of
possession is something that the
hellstrom series trades heavily on
in a much larger sense with many demons
running around possessing humans all
over the place
but when it also talks about the body
burning itself out that's a reference to
ghostwriter's trademark flames when the
spirit of vengeance manifests its power
in a host
it's also a reference to demons draining
the essence from humans metaphorically
burning through their life force before
they jump to another host like their
energy vampires
and obviously the flaming skull graphic
that they use in the trailer is
ghostwriter's head every version of
ghost rider
and the chain the ghostwriter used
number four the connection between
ghostrider and hellstrom is that they've
teamed up a whole bunch in the comics
both being big supernatural marvel
characters
usually it's hellstrom appearing in
ghost rider adventures like he joined a
version of the midnight suns during
marvel zombies
they're actually doing a marvel zombies
episode of the avengers what if series
on disney plus next year this is the
trailer footage of that
some heroes will rise
others will fall
you may have heard an awesome voice
narrate that piece
the watcher played in this series by the
amazing jeffrey wright
the watcher is a being the non-earthly
being
who observes all things he's
watching over the multiverse we'll see
where we take it
we could take it anywhere zombie captain
america versus the winter soldier it
looks like he's wearing a version of his
costume from avengers infinity war in
avengers end game which means that the
marvel zombies episode might actually be
an avengers end game or an infinity war
episode
the way that kevin feige explained that
is that the marvel what if series is
doing episodes for each of the mcu
movies so the first episode will be
released next summer season one's only
10 episodes
they haven't released the complete list
of which episodes they're doing in
season one we know some of them
but episode one will be what if captain
america the first avenger
no zombies as far as i know in that one
that's just what if steve rogers became
a version of iron man instead of captain
america in the 1940s with a hardcore
tank version of the suit built by howard
stark and what if peggy carter gets the
super soldier serum to become captain
britain
because she's a member of the british
forces so see what they did there
everybody always wondering if they'd
ever do captain britain in the mcu this
is the first version of that character
they'll probably do a more modern
version at some point
they actually did reference captain
britain when captain america went back
and almost got caught by peggy carter
when they were trying to return the
stone of the 1970s she mentions an agent
braddock
that is captain britain in the comics
but it seems like the marvel zombies
episode will be the avengers turning
into zombies during one of the big
avengers movies either infinity war
or endgame so it'll be cool to see what
event causes the zombies either they
turn into zombies or zombies invade from
the multiverse which is actually closer
to the plot of the original marvel
zombies comic book where you have
zombies traveling the multiverse eating
other universes
i'll talk more about that crazy stuff
when we get more footage of it next year
it's going to be a while before we get more
trailers for what if
number three ghostwriter the actual mcu
character was originally going to get
his own tv show on hulu that would have
crossed over with hellstrom and a couple
other supernatural shows in a big
netflix marvel style team-up event
called
adventure interfere that was meant to be
a reference to the original marvel comic
book series called adventure into fear
which is sort of a catch-all
horror supernatural sci-fi book that
marvel published a long time ago
the ghost rider tv show got cancelled
right before they started to film
episodes they were almost ready to go
it was going to be robbie reyes
ghostwriter from agents of shield they
weren't really clear if they were going
to incorporate
all the story lines from his seasons of
agents of shield it sounded like they
were going to retune the character just
a little bit for his series but they did
a version of his origin on agents of
shield
they ended his run on the show right
before avengers infinity war happened
and he started talking about this big
interdimensional war that the spirit of
vengeance had involved him in that went
far beyond the pale of anything that
coulson or the other agents could
comprehend
like you all think this stuff is bad you
have no idea what kind of wars raging
across the multiverse right now between
supernatural forces
everyone kind of assumed that they would
pay that off during a next doctor
strange movie like doctor strange too
but they never really took it farther
than that on the tv show
aside from coulson himself getting to be
a host to the spirit of vengeance
coulson ghost rider was actually a
pretty cool twist on the character
number two i think what happened though
is that kevin feige took control of all
the marvel tv shows development and
started bringing
all their tv shows for the most part to
disney plus instead of giving them away
to other platforms like netflix or
broadcast tv like abc
he probably just decided they wanted to
keep the ghostwriter character in his
pocket for future potential crossovers
with people
like moon knight the new blade reboot
movie or any other darker horror-based
stuff that they do during marvel phase 4
marvel phase 5.
i think it's going to be marvel phase 5
before we see the blade movie
and that would be the place where you
would put a version of ghost rider
so when ghostwriter does come back in
the mcu it probably won't be the robbie
reyes version from agents of shield it'd
probably be a totally new actor playing
a different version of the character
but the hellstrom tv show will still be
referencing all that ghost rider
supernatural adventure interfere
crossover stuff that they were
originally trying to set up
all the big changes that they made to
those shows the hulu shows that they
wound up canceling and the netflix shows
didn't really happen until after they
had filmed hellstrom so we'll see how
much stuff they include in that
it's only going to be one season so it's
more like a limited series
marvel is still doing the animated
howard the duck series though from kevin
smith on hulu
and the modoc series that's going to be
pat and oswalt doing the voice of modoc
new york comic-con is coming up but i
don't think they're gonna have trailers
for those series till sometime next year
right before they release them
but number one bringing back around to
doctor strange too i know there have
been
all kinds of rumors about ghost rider
easter eggs and doctor strange too
and crazy cameos from the multiverse
like tom cruise iron man
i don't know if the iron man stuff is
true that's just a rumor right now
but the connection between dr strange
and hellstrom is that they also teamed
up a lot in the comics in the mcu kevin
feige said that they were using the
doctor strange movies is the path to set
up blade
vampires the darker supernatural
characters of the mcu
i don't know if that means we're going
to also see moon knight eventually cross
over with doctor strange because it
sounds like we might actually be getting
the moon knight episodes around the time
that doctor strange 2 hits theaters
in 2022 they've been making a bunch of
casting announcements for the marvel
disney plus series recently we just
found out who miss marvel is she's a
brand new actress you've probably never
heard of before
but we just found out about tatiana
maslany she hook a couple weeks ago
they'll announce who's going to be
playing moon knight real soon and the
other characters that are going to show
up on the hawkeye series
but hawkeye will come before moon night
it sounds like moon knight will be one
of the last series to premiere
the other big show though that's going
to be crossing over with doctor strange
2 is wandavsion we'll be getting new
wandavision episodes later this year
sometime by december at least if not a
little bit sooner
of course i'll be doing episode in
easter egg videos for all that stuff so
as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you'll see all that stuff
while you wait for everything click here
for that new avengers wandavision
trailer in easter eggs and click here
for the brand new mandalorian season 2
trailer in star wars easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe this is the way!